(audience applauds)
- Every once in a while
an idea comes around
that disrupts everything.
The printing press,
the light bulb,
this ass,
and now this.
- What if we told you, you,
you, you
that we could
eradicate inequality.
- Poverty.
- And general douchiness in
a matter of (snaps) seconds.
- [All] We bring to you,
white tax.
(audience applauds)
- Do something racist;
- Your ass will get taxed.
- We will take away
one thing related
to the group or
groups you offended.
(audience applauds)
- [Stage Member] white tax.
- While sitting on the bus,
Doris Roberts, white American;
reaches forward to braid
Jasmine Jordan's hair
without permission.
Suddenly, every
black female artist
is erased from her
iTunes including Beyonce.
Her strut,
her life,
her sex,
forever offbeat.
- white tax.
(audience gasps)
- Six members of Kuma
Kuma Kapzalon Fraternity,
dress in sombreros and put
fake mustaches on their faces
as they drink margaritas
and eat tacos.
- We will construct a wall
around the frat house.
Not letting ***** in,
or racism out.
- white tax.
- Jared Spalding,
white American;
calls the police on his
neighbor, Jack Newman
for entering his own home.
Jared's artistic and
food taste is eradicated.
He spends his remaining
days watching Blue Bloods
and eating white bread.
- white tax.
(sliding sound)
- James Powell, pulls at
the skin of his face to make
slanty eyes and speaks in a
made-up language he credits
as Chinese.
(audience gasps)
(stage members gasps)
- [All] Hmmm
- White people may
have invented racism-
- But they're not the
only ones guilty of it.
(audience awws)
- James must now use carrier
pigeons to send **** pics
and pine cones to wipe his ass.
You make fun of people,
you don't get to use
their inventions.
(rope skips)
- white tax.
- Josh Hunter, white American;
claims reverse racism
for not making his
basketball team.
The consequence?
Reverse slavery.
Josh Hunter's a slave.
(classical music)
(aaahs)
(dings)
- white tax.
- If these behaviors continue,
we will begin to take the
things y'all made away.
- Car and walking Bay Sports.
- NPR.
- Abba.
- Podcasts and miniseries
about one *******
wrongly accused white person
when we all know federal
penitentiaries are filled with
thousands of black
and brown people
who get in trouble
for doing ****
white people do all the time!
- Vegan mayonnaise.
- (sing-songs) Finding yourself.
- Jeff Goldblum.
- [Stage Member]
Yeah, Jeff Goldblum.
- Yeah. We want his fine ass.
- So shape up-
- Or get your **** taken.
- [All] White tax!
(audience applauds)